after a two-year hiatus aid for aids in
nevada their annual aids walk returns in
person on sunday may 1st at sunset park
here to tell us more about it is andrew
ryan the a fan marketing director it is
great to see you wonderful to see you in
person in studio this
this is a show girl behind me hi
these are the girls from extravaganza
they are they're going to be joining us
at the walk along with some incredible
entertainers from all of our favorite
shows on the strip how excited are you
new location this year what can we
expect this year at the walk
well you know we're moving to a brand
new venue sunset park we've never done
it there before we've moved to different
locations all up and down the strip and
around las vegas but this is the first
time we'll be at sunset park we have
trees grass lakes all the things that
we're missing everywhere else in vegas
we're excited that you guys are back
such a great calls and new this year the
5k that's a new element is it not brand
new first time ever 5k in the 32 years
we've done the aids walk this is the
first time we're incorporating a 5k that
is huge let's go back to the very first
one we were talking about before we went
on the air here the first one 1984 or so
and that took place just on the strip
you guys did the very first walk yeah
you know
like many of the events during the
height of the aids pandemic people were
just coming together it was you know
kind of grassroots and and coming
together to make a difference and raise
money to fight and so you know it's
evolved so much and like the black and
white party it's gone the venues keep
getting bigger yeah and the
entertainment keeps getting better and
the support from the entertainment on
this trip has been incredible shows like
extravaganza chippendales wow brand new
shows like rouge and stratosphere are
joining us so it's going to be a great
chance to see them all in one place the
showgirls everyone's going to be out
there let's talk about the grand
marshals penn and teller involved every
single year they're back this year what
can we expect from penn and teller ken
and teller are back at the helm you know
we we love having them there they're an
incredible incredible act on the strip
that has really you know longest running
headliners right more could you ask for
right exactly and they've graciously
agreed again to partner with us and help
spread the word and be our advocates in
the community and nationally to bring
awareness to this cause and you raise so
much money every single year where do
the proceeds go a hundred percent of the
proceeds go right here in nevada to afan
aid for aids in nevada to help fight hiv
aids right here in our community so
uniquely you know there is a lot of
fundraisers and a lot of events in las
vegas but we are very proud to say that
100 of the money that we race stays here
in the community to make a difference
such a great cause you guys do great
things do you have showgirls everywhere
you go this i i like this is a nice
setup we can walk around town you know
our show girls behind us change our last
name to goodman grab some martinis and
let's go yeah the mayor right here thank
you for being here ladies how do people
sign up for the walk athan lv.org go to
the website it's very easy to register
and the great thing about it is it's a
peer-to-peer fundraiser so not only when
you register do you make a donation but
you can share it on your social media
and you can ask your friends to donate
as little as a dollar every single
dollar makes a difference and we set our
goal at 100 000 this year and we're
almost there and we have two weeks to go
and then we're gonna get it we gotta
make it we gotta do it if there are
businesses are out there and they wanna
do like a corporate sponsorship or put
together a a team with their business or
corporate team can they still do that
absolutely and that information is on
the website as well i love it thank you
so much for joining us ladies thank you
so much we appreciate it you can stay
around all show if you like to just
follow us around
we have lots more to come